(electronic music)
- (Greg) Hey Wisecrack, Greg here!When making a short
list of “really funny things,” chronic despair
and unrelenting anxiety probably don’t make
the cut. So why are so many comedians these
days talking about their mental health? And more
importantly, why is it still so freaking funny?
- (Jake Wiesman) I knew that I
was gaining weight because my
belt stopped fitting around my
neck the same that it used to.
- (Greg) Indeed, over the last few years--and
especially since Robin Williams’ tragic death
in 2014-we’ve seen more and more comics making
material out of their struggles with depression,
anxiety, and other mental health
issues. Pete Davidson, for example,
has made a running gag of his mental
health issues on Saturday Night Live:
- (Davidson) Oh no no no. I was born
depressed, but it might make me feel better
if I was on TV more!
- (Greg) And Aparna Nancherla has similarly used
her anxiety as fuel for some excellent jokes:
- (Nancherla) And like if you don't have
Anxiety, the way I would describe it
is like there's an edgy improv team in your brain.
- (Greg) And John Mulaney has been cracking
jokes about his own mental health struggles
and addiction issues since early on in his career:
- (Mulaney) I actually just quit drinking a
month ago... (someone boos) oh I'm not
exactly slap happy about it myself.
- (Greg) Meanwhile, comics like Bill
Hader and Bo Burnham have been open
about their experiences with performance anxiety:
- (Burnham) To come to terms with your
anxiety, on the road... you know what I mean,
in front of thousands of people
a night, it's very very abstract.
- (Greg) Now, stand up comedy
might not seem like the most
obvious medium for exploring mental health
struggles given that, for most of its history,
it’s peddled largely in quips, punchlines,
and gags purely for laughter’s sake.
- (Mitch Hedberg) I wish they made fajita
cologne, cuz that stuff smells good.
- (Greg) But this recent shift
raises some interesting questions.
For one thing, how did we get
from Bob-Hope-style one-liners:
- (Bob Hope) I went to the dentist
this morning and I only had a dollar.
- (Man) What happened?
- (Bob Hope) I had to get buck teeth!
- (Greg) To comedians dissecting the most
intimate details of their mental health struggles?
- (Patton Oswalt) If I’d had a gun right here, I
would've just bought it up, one smooth movement.
Just going like, "Oh they have French
crust pizza" (singing, mimics gunshot)
- (Greg) And is this change a good thing? Are
jokes about anxiety, depression, and other mental
health issues, just a new way to get a quick laugh
out of a tough situation? Or is there
much deeper going on? Let’s find out in this
Wisecrack Edition on Comedy and Mental Health.
- (Greg) While it’s no longer particularly
shocking to hear a comedian joke about depression,
it’s worth remembering that the recent focus on
mental health in stand-up is pretty unprecedented.
For most of its history, stand-up comedy was
less about sharing funny confessional stories or
observations on stage, and more about crafting
and delivering clever setups and punchlines.
- (Steven Wright) My friend George is a radio
announcer and when he walks under
a bridge you can't hear him talk.
- (Greg) In other words, comics in the early
to mid-20th century largely focused on laughter
for its own sake, and didn’t necessarily ground
their material in their real-life experiences.
Comics like Bob Hope--along with Jack Benny
and Milton Berle--built their sets around
rapid-fire jokes.While their setups often made
reference to their personal lives, this was only
incidental. The real goal wasn’t baring their soul
on stage, it was landing a surprising punchline:
- (Milton Berle) And when
I arrived at the airport,
LBJ gave me a wonderful reception a 21 gun
salute. And I got the powder burns to prove it.
- (Greg) The comedy of this era tended to be
escapist--more about taking a break from life’s
hardships than engaging them head-on.Key
to that comedic escape is something called
incongruity. That is, deliberately creating a gap
between what the audience is expecting to hear
and what actually comes out of the comedian’s
mouth. Philosophers as disparate as Kant,
Schopenhaur, and Kierkegaard have theorized
that incongruity is the main ingredient
in generating laughter: We laugh when
something disrupts our usual mental patterns
and subverts our expectations. The classic
example is the person who slips on a banana peel
while walking. The expectation here is: This
person can walk. We are very used to seeing
this. We are not used to seeing a person eat
shit instead. Thus, the incongruity. Of course,
this bit has become so cliche that it’s
practically an expectation in its own right,
which opens up the floor for
new banana-peel-related gags:
In pursuit of incongruity, some comedians
got downright weird with their sets,
creating completely nonsensical material in an
attempt to buck the audience’s expectations.
Standup comedian Charlie Callas, for
instance, made a decades-long career out
of interrupting his own stories with bizarre,
nonsensical noises and facial expressions:
- (Charlie Callas) Hello! Is this (honks)
Is this - (honks) Is this - (honks)
- (Greg)
Even more abstractly, 80’s prop comic Gallagher
built entire sets around smashing watermelons
with a hammer and pulling large
things out of a giant couch?
- (Gallagher) Crap there's a
potato chip... A big old crayon!
- (Greg)
Hey, it was a different time! Audiences
attending these kinds of shows probably
weren’t expecting a lot in the way of substance.
But even before Gallagher’s watermelon smashing,
comedy was evolving to do more than just dish
out jokes. Beginning in the 1950’s and 60’s,
a so-called “New Wave” of stand-up comics like
Lenny Bruce and George Carlin began to push the
boundaries of what could be said on-stage
by incorporating crude humor and social
satire into their sets. Carlin, for instance,
was famously arrested on obscenity charges
following a televised routine about the
dirty words one wasn’t supposed to say on TV:
(George Carlin, censored swears)
- (Greg) In a similar vein, comics like Sam
Kinnison used their stage time to attack
social norms and institutions
generally considered sacred:
- (Sam Kinnison) So, Michael,
if you ever think about getting
married, if you ever think you've meet
the right woman and you want to settle
down, and change your life. Can you do me a
favor Mike? Remember this face- (screams)
- (Greg) More so than earlier comedians, these
comics acted as cultural critics, pointing out
perceived hypocrisies. Throughout history, this
has been a major function of comedy and laughter.
As scholar Lawrence E. Mintz writes - the standup
comic acts as “our comic spokesperson, a mediator,
an ‘articulator’ of our culture, and
our contemporary anthropologist.”
- (Greg) More broadly, Mintz contends that, in
certain contexts, the standup comic is granted
permission to express feelings that would be
difficult to share outside the comedy club.
- (Bill Hicks) You are Satan's spawn,
filling the world with violent garbage.
You are (censored) kill yourself, it's
the only way to save your f**** soul.
- (Greg) While performing, a skilled comic can
enact an audience’s frustrations with the very
real difficulties of relationships,
politics, and so on. In this way,
they can provide insights into our shared
human shortcomings--insights that would
be entirely unacceptable to share at the
company picnic. Still, for the most part,
New Wave comics tended to direct that
criticism outward, at the broader society,
rather than attempting introspection. And
that’s what’s so interesting about the present
moment - which we will playfully dub the Nü New
Age of comedy. More so than ever before, comics
are turning a Carlin-esque critical eye inward
to comment on themselves and their community.
- (Jordan Temple) Yeah I think it's hard
for black men especially to talk about
depression because we have so many cool words
available to us to undermine how we really feel.
- (Greg) As a result, they’re able to
broach hard truths that, for years,
have been off the table even
for the boldest of comics.
- (Daniel Fernandes) And trust me when I say this,
nothing is scarier than
having to fight your own mind.
- (Greg) But is this necessarily a
good thing? That brings us to one of
the central conflicts in this Nu New Age:
Namely, is laughter A. the best medicine,
- (Patton Oswalt) Hey, uh where you know
everything you do is going to end in
annihilation and entropy so what's the point? I'm
like, **** you're right, you win again depression.
- (Greg) or B. an unhealthy coping mechanism?
- (Chris Gethard) Depressed, f**** up,
looking for any excuse to not get help
and the fact that some of my heroes were...
messed up was a justification for that.
- (Greg) That clip’s from Laughing Matters,
a recent documentary about comedy and mental
health. In it, famous actors and
comics including Sarah Silverman,
Wayne Brady, and Rainn Wilson speak candidly
about the mental health issues they’ve dealt with,
and explore the role that comedy
has played in their struggles.The
documentary explores the potential harm of using
comedy to escape one’s mental health problems.
- (Sara Benincasa) I think performing can be
a temporary high, but like all temporary highs
it... doesn't last. And you can chase that high,
night after night after night... but eventually
there's gonna be a club that's not open
or you're gonna have a night off. And you're gonna
have to deal with what happens in the silence.
- (Greg) Like any other addiction, the high of a
great performance can temporarily mask the pain
of depression, anxiety, and so on. But
it does so without actually helping to
solve the underlying issues. And in
some cases, it can make them worse.
- (Chris Gethard) And if you are thinking of
doing comedy as a substitute for therapy...
it doesn't work, I tried. I tried
for a long time. It doesn't work.
- (Greg) To put it bluntly, the documentary
suggests that comedy and laughter have been
unproductive and even destructive for many
comedians--a way to tune out from a life that’s
falling apart. If that’s true, is it fixable? And
specifically, is there a more constructive way to
make people laugh, one that’s less about avoiding
painful truths, and more about facing them? To
find out, we can turn to a guy who’s not exactly
known for his punchy one-liners - philosopher and
horse enthusiast Friedrich Nietzsche. In general,
Nietzsche had pretty serious beef with laughter,
because he viewed it as a potential threat
to our quest for self actualization.
As scholar Mark Weeks notes, Nietzche
thought the most important human pursuit
was embracing our future, our desires, and
our power in the face of life’s absurdities.
For him, laughter undercuts this pursuit. Indeed,
according to Weeks’s interpretation of Nietzsche,
laughter, with its ability to ground us in
the present moment by overwhelming us with
giggle-fits and good feelings, can distract
from the all important philosophical quest:
Constantly striving to improve ourselves in order
to build a better future. To put it another way:
laughter has a tendency to lift us momentarily out
of time by cutting tension and poking holes in the
stories we construct for ourselves. Laughter, in
other words, is a loss of the creative tension
that the Nietzschean hero needs to construct
a meaningful narrative of their life--a
waste of a vital resource. While
Nietzsche is hardly an expert in lulz,
and stand-up comedy as we know it today didn’t
exist in 19th century Germany,he does have a
point worth considering.As we’ve seen, a lot of
successful comedy works by creating incongruity,
pointing out gaps between expectation and reality:
in other words, undercutting various narratives
we tell ourselves about the way things ought to
go. Charlie Callas does this by literally cutting
himself off while he tells a brief story, and Sam
Kinnison does this by poking holes in the societal
narrative of happy, loving marriage. In various
ways, comedians have historically generated a lot
of laughter by disrupting the flow of personal
and societal narratives. Going by Nietzsche,
we might consider this a bad thing because,
while comedians are deconstructing old
and useless narratives, they’re not necessarily
offering new, more productive ones to take their
place.And to bring it back to mental health: in
Nietzschean terms, comedy has failed some funny
people by offering them a way to temporarily
undercut the narrative of their own lives.
In the process, they can numb out and avoid
facing their own existential dread, and the
mental health issues that might come with it. A
lot of existing stand-up comedy, in other words,
confirms Nietzsche’s worst fears about laughter’s
potentially harmful effects on the human spirit.
- (Steve Martin) Well excuse me!!!
- (Greg) We can’t help but wonder if Nietzsche
might have been more okay with laughter
if he spent his time joking with friends
instead of crying alone in the woods.
Which, hey, hey, hey, you do
you, Friedrich. Nevertheless,
his criticism raises a question: should comics
try to use laughter to confront their problems,
rather than to escape from them?And what might
such a new approach be? While we have no evidence
that any of the comedians interviewed in Laughing
Matters dig Neitzche, they do outline what a
more constructive approach to comedy might look
like - specifically an approach that transforms
their struggles into something of greater
value, rather than just fodder for laughter:
- (Rainn Wilson) We all have these kind
of **** things that happen to us. And
we can get through em, you know? We can get
through it, and transform it, and use it!
- (Greg) Trauma and tragedy, according to these
comics, are not merely things to laugh at,
even if it feels good. Rather, they are
the raw materials the comedian can use
to craft entirely new narratives, instead
of merely shredding apart outdated ones.
- (Chris Gethard) You know, if you’re an artist,
who has a chance to say something that might
actually connect people org els people and you
don't take that chance... what good are you?
- (Greg) This approach to comedy is distinctly
Nietzschean. Mark Weeks contends that, in his
later work, the philosopher made a kind of uneasy
peace with laughter, by “challeng[ing] his readers
to will a new kind of laughter,” one which leaves
us both amused AND philosophically elevated.
To put it another way, Nietzsche believed that
a constructive, self-affirming laughter was
possible, but had yet to be realized in his own
time. He challenged his readers to invent a new
form of laughter that would support heroic
striving in the face of adversity, rather
than denigrating such efforts as being pointless
and silly.And we’d argue that the standup comic
who uses their struggles with mental health as
material is helping to make that new laughter a
reality.When a comic crafts a good story about
their struggles, they aren’t JUST entertaining
-- they’re also creating a “heroic narrative” that
shows them facing off against the real challenges
of being human. In the case of mental health, that
means the difficulty of being completely reliant
on a blob of electrified goo that frequently
malfunctions. In other words, they’re responding
to Nietzsche’s challenge by generating laughter
that brings audiences--and themselves--into
direct contact with the past and the future,
rather than merely escaping into the hilarity of
the present.We can see this in the work of Sarah
Silverman. Like the other comedians interviewed
in Laughing Matters, she cites her difficult
childhood as a sort of origin story for her
comedy career. In this way, she takes a direct
look at her past, rather than running from it:
- (Silverman) A hundred percent of
comedians become comedians because
somewhere in their childhood, they
needed to be funny in order to survive.
- (Greg) Her refusal to use laughter as a
way of covering up past traumas pops up again
when Silverman describes what happened to the
doctor who prescribed her Xanax as a teenager:
- (Silverman) The psychiatrist who originally
put me on it... hung himself. (laughs)
I mean I can't just skate by that, it's crazy.
- (Greg) Notice how Silverman laughs
and smiles while telling the story,
but refuses to dismiss her psychiatrist’s suicide
as something inconsequential. She can acknowledge
the irony in the situation, and even chuckle
at it, without denying the traumatic effect
that these events had on her younger self. What’s
more, she explains precisely what that effect was,
drawing a narrative arc from her past
through her present and into the future:
- (Silverman) These years of torture
and shame kind of became my superpower.
- (Greg) Silverman is literally framing her comedy
career in terms of a superhero’s origin story. Far
from avoiding her problems, Silverman embraces
them as a key part of her creative process,
without romanticizing them as the sole source
of her funniness. Depression doesn’t make a joke
out of Silverman: Silverman makes jokes out of
depression. She demonstrates that comedians can
transform mental health struggles from a taboo
subject into something worth talking about,
even celebrating, if only for the
duration of a set. Aparna Nancherla,
for her part, applies a similar
technique to the topic of anxiety:
- (Nancherla) I feel like it’s weirder to not have
anxiety than to have it. Cus I feel like if you're
not scared, you're not paying attention,
you know? Like I feel like if you open a
newspaper today and skim maybe three headlines
you're just like, seems cool! It's like what!
Everything's on fire! Even the newspaper's
on fire! What are you so chill about?
- (Greg) Here, Nancherla frames anxiety not as
a failing, but as the only rational response to
a society that insists we post happy photos of
ourselves on Instagram while the world crumbles
around us. That’s not to say that everyone
needs to get stoked on their own depression
or anxiety - but it’s one way to deal.Comics
can also transform trauma into connection,
with other comics or audience members, or
insomniacs watching grainy videos on Youtube.
- (Sara) It's one of the reasons
that I love being a comedian,
because if I can find comedy people
anywhere I go in the world, and I have,
I know I'm gonna hear good stories. And I'm
gonna be sitting around with people who are
also, if not ok with being **** up, at least
perhaps more honest than other folks might be.
- (Greg) And what’s more Neitzchean
than transforming trauma into purpose?
By using their darkest moments to
generate laughter, these comics aren’t
just constructing their own heroic narratives:
they’re offering us the chance to create ours,
too. In other words, if this guy can use
humor to overcome his mental health struggles
then maybe there’s hope for us and
our friends and our cranky coworkers.
- (Chris Gethard) The real mission is if your kid
is sick, or your cousin is suffering, or the guy
on the other side of the cubicle wall shows up and
you never know which person you're going to get.
How can I make those people understand
that that person's not being a dickhead that
day, and that person is not being melodramatic,
and that person isn't going through a
phase, but it's because that person is sick.
- (Greg) By making comedy intended to keep
us alive and striving for something greater,
these comedians are generating a kind
of laughter which Nietzsche might be
darn proud of--a laughter that serves
to construct, rather than to tear down.
And that’s nothing to laugh at.
Just kidding! It’s pretty funny.
- (Patton Oswalt) I don't want to be out in
the wasteland fat and depressed! Like that,
there's not gonna be any
Prozac after the collapse.
- (Greg) But what do you guys think? Can comedy
help us all become better people? Or should
comedians stick to smashing watermelons? Shout
out to Gallagher! Let us know in the comments!And
since we’re on the subject, if you or anyone you
know is going through a hard time, yo please reach
out and ask for help. Mostly because you deserve
it inherently, but also because y’all mean a lot
to us. And if you ever need it, you can find the
link and phone number for the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline here and in the description
below. Big thanks to our patrons for all your
support. Be sure to subscribe and ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching, folks. Peace.